merci jimmy bonjour à toutes et à tous
bonjour carnel fourdrinier la journée ce
carnage voilà la cannelle fourdrinier
vous êtes membre du collectif des
ouvriers et ouvrières agricoles
empoisonné par les pesticides
alors on le précise pour ceux qui ne
regardent pas sur internet puis qui nous
écoutent vous êtes une jeune militante
de ce collectif des ouvriers et
ouvrières agricoles empoisonnées par des
pesticides
vous êtes venu nous parler d'une journée
de manifestation demain en soutien à ce
collectif une journée baptisée doute
pour réparation mais vous allez nous
expliquer pourquoi justement vous
organiser à nouveau cette mobilisation
parce que nous on avait cru qu'avec l'
annonce il ya quelques semaines de
dépistage gratuit du taux de chlordécone
dans le sens et notamment pour pour ce
cette partie de la population qui est
particulièrement ciblée et oscille
annonce donc de la mise en oeuvre du
plan chlordécone cat et bien que cette
question de réparation des préjudices
subis étaient en passe d'être réglé
alors tout le propos du collectif et de
visibiliser les ouvriers les ouvriers
agricoles qui jusqu'à présent été
ostracisés et en visibiliser y compris
et à commencer par le plan chlordécone 4
puisque dans les publics ciblés comme
étant prioritaire ne figurait pas les
ouvriers les ouvriers agricoles qui
pourtant était en première ligne lors de
l'épandage des produits phytosanitaires
sans protection d'ailleurs la plupart du
temps et donc c'est à force de lobbying
politique que le collectif a obtenu le
dépistage gratuit du taux de chlordécone
dans le sens pour les ouvriers agricoles
et a fortiori pour le reste de la
population
quand ce sera possible mais alors cette
avance est là elle aurait pu satisfaire
il ya de nature à calmer un petit peu le
jeu pour ainsi dire bonsoir merci là ya
pas de jeu du tout hein on parle de
choses évidemment dramatique
oui c'est un prérequis je veux dire il
faut pouvoir doser le taux de
chlordécone et des autres pesticides
puisqu'il ya plus d'une soixantaine de
substances actives qui ont été utilisés
de 1975
de 1960 à nos jours uniquement dans la
banane donc reste encore la canne à
sucre les champs d'ananas de citron
d'avocats et c est donc c'est un pré
requis pour pouvoir doser le taux de
chlordécone et des autres pesticides
dans le sang pour pouvoir établir un
lien de causalité entre les pathologies
dont sont affectés les ouvriers et les
ouvrières et leur contamination aux
produits phytosanitaires en raison de
leur activité professionnelle mais aussi
de leur lieu d'habitation puisque la
plupart d'entre elles et eux habitent
soient dans ou aux abords des
plantations donc finalement il ya encore
des choses à réclamer et à obtenir
c'est pour ça que justement vous
organiser cette manifestation et que
vous appeler au soutien de la population
alors on va développer un petit peu
chacune des quelques revendications je
crois qu'un à 11 ans tout c'est ça c'est
ça y'a un stand revendications on peut
pas on peut pas les détails et ce matin
mais vous demandez par exemple le
collectif des ouvriers et ouvrières
agricoles en empoisonné par les
pesticides demande des soins gratuits de
toutes les pathologies tout à fait entre
autres donc il ya la prise en charge de
toutes les pathologies puisque de tous
les frais qui sont afférents aux
pathologies puisqu'on l'a mené une
enquête de terrain qui a mis en lumière
que neuf ouvriers et ouvrières sur dix
sont atteints et atteintes de
pathologies graves donc des cancers en
tous genres parfois en cumulant
plusieurs cancers de la polyarthrite
rhumatoïde des troubles musculo
squelettiques des problèmes d'ordre
cardiaque alzheimer parkinson tout ça
avec des attestations médicales enfin ça
a été c'est pas les ces maladies ne sont
pas encore reconnues comme maladies
professionnelles c'est d'ailleurs l'une
des revendications du collectif
également puisque les ouvriers les
ouvriers agricoles c'est l'une des
seules professions qui n'a pas de
tableaux de maladies professionnelles
à l'exception de la maladie de parkinson
du lymphome non hodgkinien donc
donc le but justement c'est d'obtenir la
prise en charge de tous ces soins
puisque la plupart d'entre elles doivent
partir se faire soigner en france et
donc doivent payer un billet d'avion
tout en sachant qu'ils elles sont
extrêmement précaire puisque en étant à
la retraite le montant de leur retraite
oscille entre 130 et 700 euros
donc il faut une prise en charge des
services de l'état de la sécurité
sociale et autres organismes exact qui
interviennent dans ce champ là c'est
l'une des revendications aussi qui qui
est présenté par ce collectif et qui le
sera encore demain également une
retraite minimum de 1000 euros minimum
minimum on a bien compris ça peut pas
être fait que les 92 millions d'euros
qui sont prévus pour le plan chlordécone
4 on ne peut pas en prendre une partie
pour eux alors je crois pas que ça
vraiment les attributions du plan
chlordécone 4 mais à force est de
constater que de toute façon à 92
millions d'euros c'est un budget somme
toute insuffisante puisque c'est un
budget qui s'étalera sur six ans et qui
est prévu pour la guadeloupe et pour la
martinique donc ne serait ce que des
pistes et l'ensemble de la population
uniquement pour le taux de chlordécone
dans le sens et pas pour les autres
produits phytosanitaires finalement deux
tiers du budget du plan chlordécone
quatre ils seront consacrés donc
finalement ce plan c'est une vaste
opération de communication mais qui ne
se traduit pas vraiment par des mesures
concrètes et donc selon vous avec ce
plan on est loin du compte encore au oui
complètement cessé de la poudre aux yeux
mais est-ce que ce que j'aimerais
rappeler c'est que en préambule de ses
11 points de revendications et qui a un
prix un pré requis nécessaires à la
satisfaction de ses revendications
c'est la reconnaissance par l'état de sa
responsabilité dans ce marasme
économique social et sanitaire mais
également une reconnaissance de la part
des békés de leur implication dans ce
scandale dernières revendications parmi
les onze qu'on peut décliner rapidement
avant d'en venir aux modalités pratiques
de la journée de demain
vous n'avez qu'à mais également la
suppression de la taxe foncière tout à
fait puisque on est face à des gens qui
pour la plupart d'entre elles est vive
dans ou aux abords des habitations sont
installés depuis cinq six voire plus de
génération et qui ont payé toutes des
loyers voir ont acheté les terres et
aujourd'hui ne bénéficient toujours pas
de titre de propriété puisque les békés
refuse de leur concéder alors même que
c'est un droit qu'ils ont payé pour ça
et donc on leur demande de payer une
taxe foncière ce qui en plus est
illégale puisque normalement la taxe
foncière se doit d'être basé sur un
titre de propriété
et on est face à des gens qui touchent
une maigre retraite comme je vous
l'expliquais qu'ils sont pas
propriétaires mais à qui on demande 2000
auraient tous deux mille euros de taxe
foncière
quand on a deux cents lots 6 en moyenne
c'est une moyenne mais on est face à des
gens qui ont 200 ou 600 euros de
retraite à qui on demande de s'acquitter
d'une taxe foncière de 2000 euros donc
que cc annuel entendu alors donc demain
cette journée donc on le rappelle
baptisé double août pour réparation
alors on venait d'expliquer pourquoi
justement il est question de réparation
à votre esprit donc ça va se passer au
lamentin à nouveau donc au quartier
bouchette quartier alors emblématique
non pas qu lamentin pas que in également
avoir de pourquoi donc à 9h30 il y aura
un départ à la place de l'abbé grégoire
hauteur 100 villes avec des chaises
roulantes des ambulances et des
vaisselles qui seront mises à
disposition des perses des ouvriers les
ouvrir qui ne sont pas en mesure de se
mouvoir en raison de leur pathologie
donc le but c'est de visibiliser
justement l'état sanitaire de cette
population
donc tout le monde y est convié à un
bien évidemment puisque ce qu'il faut
bien comprendre c'est que tant que les
droits des ouvriers et des ouvrières
agricoles ne seront pas assurés
finalement ceux du reste de la
population non plus et en témoigne la
satisfaction de votre point de
revendication tendant au dépistage du
chlordécone et des autres pesticides
dans le sens pour les ouvriers agricoles
dispositif qui sera étendue au reste de
la population
et puis ensuite on aura un hommage qui
sera rendu aux deux ouvriers agricoles
et à l'ouvrière assassiné par les forces
de l'ordre le 20 et le 24 mars 1961 dans
le cadre d'une grève ouvrière donc au
lamentin en compagnie de monsieur le
maire et puis ensuite un départ à
brochettes ou la restauration sera
assurée également avec une table ronde
2 avec des associations sur les
perspectives quand ça c'est dans
l'après-midi un c dans l'après midi
voilà remis de ses droits c'est dans
l'après-midi et puis ensuite il y aura
un moment bêler avec le groupe canigou
et puis en une manifestation culturelle
avec divers artistes gilbert sera non
ralph thamar kolo barst et des défis qui
sont annoncées pour demain soir donc
quartier bouchet tôt au lamentin avec le
collectif des ouvriers et ouvrières
agricoles employés empoisonné par les
pesticides pour terminer cannelle
fourdrinier puisque vous êtes méditant
de deux ans faisant partie de ce
collectif le thème de la table ronde
justement de deux du milieu d'après midi
c'est quelle action commune et
consensuelle commune et consensuelle
pour poursuivre la lutte pour la
réparation du crime d'empoisonnement
alors très bien mais je vois que vous
avez reçu le soutien officiel du parti
communiste français du secrétaire
national du pcf famille roussel qui a
publié un communiqué qui date du 25 mars
donc là c'est tout récent il ya quelques
heures
stop au chlordécone bon clairement il
apporte le soutien à votre collectif
mais est ce qu'il n'ya pas un risque
finalement que alors tout soutien est
bon à prendre mais voilà peut-être que
ça peut faire fuir certains ou les faire
hésiter sur une lutte qui est un peu
idéologisé politiquement alors je crois
pas que la lutte puisse être idéologisé
politiquement en soit on est humaniste
et on est pour le respect des droits
humains soit on ne l'est pas il convient
de rappeler que la ctm a voté une motion
à l'unanimité en soutien des 11 points
de revendications du collectif
ce qui est quand même assez rare dans
l'histoire politique de la saison il ya
des clivages des légumes en sicile man
en martinique voilà tout à fait le sens
et de toute façon le collectif se veut
être artisan et à paris et apolitiques
donc tout le monde peut y apporter son
soutien on est allé avec tiphaine
politiques oublient tout à fait sa
démarche est éminemment politique mais
en tout cas on refuse d'être affilié à
une mouvance politique quelconque
en janvier dernier nous sommes allés à
paris en délégation pour rencontrer
divers responsables de groupes
politiques aussi bien de l'assemblée que
du sénat mais également la conseillère
santé du ministre d outre-mer vendues du
premier ministre pardon
et le conseiller outre-mer du président
de la république et pour faire du
lobbying politique donc aux roms se
troue tendances confondues voilà vous
êtes parés à l'exception du du front
national du rassemblement national oui
voilà tout à fait d'accord donc voilà le
but étant d'obtenir le plus de soutiens
possibles pour obtenir la satisfaction
des onze points de revendication que
porte le collectif merci canal
fourdrinier d'avoir répondu à ces
questions et donc demain ça commence à 9
heures sur la place abbé grégoire aux
terres sainville à fort de france
à 9h30 à 9h30 et puis dans le reste de
la journée ça va se déplacer donc au
lamentin on signale également la
projection du film
en fin d'après-midi la conquête de la
dignité de la réalisatrice martiniquaise
camille module rec
voilà je crois qu'on a quasiment tout
dit sur cette manifestation
vous êtes au courant voilà je vous
souhaite un bon week-end à toutes et à
tous rester à l écoute de nos programmes